hello everybody and welcome to episode
number 13 of my road to one bill series
today we're starting off with a hunter
level 25 Hunter the goals for this
episode are we want to get the lumbridge
medium Diaries totally done hopefully
get to 75 magic as well as if we do do
some barrows runs uh this episode might
actually be a bit longer CU we actually
made just a ton of progress in the last
week cuz I've been grinding out some
levels so hope you guys enjoy and let's
jump into it okay so we're just about to
get our hunter level up to 29 now we can
trap swamp lizzards uh Hunter has
definitely sped up quite a bit after
I've gotten these two traps available
and we'll see how swamp lizzards uh go
okay this is so much quicker I'm it's
crazy the first like few levels of a
hunter is just completely awful but it
does speed up and gets way better uh
once you get the swamp lizzards once you
get multiple traps now I'm getting like
30 40K an hour where before I was
getting like 5K so yeah definitely way
better once you get over those first few
levels so I don't know if you noticed
but I was actually aling while I was
hunting because it was just so damn slow
to begin with uh the alen some items at
the same time made it feel like less of
a waste of time uh so we did actually
get a magic level just from alen while
we were hunting and Hunter level at the
same time not bad okay so we just got 35
Hunter we kind of missed the actual
popup but uh yeah we just get to 38 and
that is one of the requirements for the
lumbridge medium Diaries so we're almost
there okay there is level 40 Hunter um
obviously I was wrong about the
requirements not 38 um but either way
we're getting there now we can set three
traps at a time I think it's actually 42
uh so hopefully this next trap will
actually speed up her experience even
more okay the best Noob got us another
58k blue feathers congratulations that a
good score however already got them I
would like to think he hunted them all
but yeah probably bought them in the
ground exchange and we're back at the
black lizards and we're about to get 42
Hunter there we go that is one of the
require requirements for the lumb medium
Diaries knocked out and we still have to
do some Rune crafting possibly some
fishing but those won't take too long
this was definitely the longest one we
needed done okay so to start off room
crafting since we're actually level one
uh we're going to go ahead and do the
abyss mini Quest I can do this at level
one all you have to do is just run
around to these four um magic Masters
who teleport you to the uh rcraft
ressence place and it gives you right to
level 9 okay there we go we just
completed the mini quest uh we're going
to get 1,000 experience uh this going to
bring us to level 9 and to be honest
like this is going to be useful for down
the line if I ever want to actually do
any Rune crafting so good to get that
out of the way okay so now we're just
finishing up uh doing some Earth orbs or
sorry Earth runes uh there's 14 Rune
crafting so now we can go do the fire
runes all the way to I think it's 25 I
need okay there's level 20 Rune crafting
H we're on to fire runes now we're using
two rings of dueling or two charges of
the Rings and dueling going back to
Castle Wars teleporting to the Dual
Arena so it's pretty quick okay there we
all that is level 23 room crafting and
that is actually the diary requirement
so we're all done pretty well we just
have to do some fishing uh but then we
can finally get the Explorers ring uh
again for farming pretty excited to have
it so one of the other requirements for
uh the lumbridge medium Diaries is H
fishing so we'll need 30 fishing so
we're at 25 now so we only need five
more levels all right so we've been
fishing trout for probably only like 25
minutes or something and we're about to
hit 30 fishing uh so we can fish a
salmon for whatever reason but we'll
keep that guy happy there we go and uh
the very last requirement is crafting so
we're going to get 38 crafting here and
that is a requirement we need we only
needed three crafting levels so it
really didn't take too long but yeah
there we go we can go start the uh easy
Diaries and then onto the medium so this
is kind of interesting I've spent N9
days here since I arrived 64 days ago
that seems quite high but I don't know
maybe it was no life in it that much so
I actually had to finish Cook's
assistant I for totally forgot I hadn't
actually done that Quest um but yeah
there we go four cooking levels as well
three cooking levels sorry and hope this
bread doesn't
burn okay we're good so we'll go ahead
and complete the easy Diaries okay there
we go guys we're just about to get
access to the Explorer ring one so far
uh which doesn't do a whole lot to begin
with um but we also do get the uh
experience lamp uh which I think we're
going to toss in agility um but yeah
explore r one and uh use this in agility
and I think that'll actually give us a
agility level uh should bring us to 54 I
think yeah
54 okay so we're working on the medium
diaries now and then we're doing
something that I've literally never done
before we're using a mythal grapple over
to this thing you need a crossbow in
this weird item but uh I don't know if
you'd ever want to use this as a
shortcut but I don't know it's kind of
cool I've never done it before okay just
like that we are done the medium Diaries
uh something we've been working for a
while on um so we got the explor Ring 2
which will teleport us right to the
fador farming patch on top of that you
get the energy restoration three times a
day as well as this uh XP lamp 7500 so
not too bad we're putting that right
into agility again and yeah happy to
have that out of the way we'll go do a
farming run and see how the ring
actually works okay so we're just about
to use the teleport right now and you
can see exactly where it pops out right
there just a little bit south of the
farming patch so that actually saves a
lot of time since this is actually one
of them that takes quite a bit of
running to get to so I'm pretty glad to
actually have that ring okay so we're
actually just about to hit another magic
level we just finished off some air orbs
that we need to charge in our bank
hopefully we get the magic level yeah
there we go that is 72 magic and uh a
little bit of cash as well we'll see how
many air orbs we have once we get back
to the bank okay so we had actually 2.5k
air orbs as well as 226 rars which gives
us 4.5 mil just from selling that off uh
so our cash stacks up back up to 6 mil
uh which is pretty decent cuz we're
going to need some uh money to invest in
alcools cuz we're going to train our
magic up pretty soon okay guys so pretty
much just because I was making a video I
actually decided to level up my herblore
and I just decided I might as well do it
on this account because I mean I need
herblore eventually anyway uh so we're
going to start off with the energy
potions we got some unfinished hair
liner potions and some chocolate dust
we're going to combine those and then
move on to prayer Potions all right
we're just finishing up the energy
potions but there is 38 her blor uh
really didn't take that long and now
we're going to start making H prayer
potions okay so we ended up buying uh
500 of each ingredients to make the
potions um we're just about to hopefully
hit a level from this not quite it looks
like we'll withdraw some random stuff
and make some potions um but it looks
like we're going to net about 200k loss
on these 500 potions which honestly is
not too bad um considering how much
experience you get for hour here it's
probably 175k an hour doing this right
now so the levels just RIP by it only
took me like an hour to get from 25 to
well 54 I guess is what I ended up with
uh but we're at 47 so far all right so
yeah we're going to sell off the potions
uh we ended up with 375 pray potion
fours because you do make threes from
the potions uh but yeah we only lost
200k so really not that bad there is
level 54 herblore so pretty much at 55
um and yeah honestly really easy to get
your prayer level up you just have to
invest a little bit of money okay so we
bought 1,250 corns and 1,250 vs of water
uh so what we're going to be doing is
combining these into unfinished corn
potions uh which are actually worth
about 2 or 300 GP more and it's really
AFK to do it's super easy you just
combine and then it does it all for you
and you just have to do another
inventory uh it's way less click
intensive um than just cleaning herbs
which is awful and yeah we'll combine
these potions and see how much money we
actually make okay so we finished
combining all the potions and they have
actually sold as well uh so we sold them
for 4018 very quickly I might add uh so
we bought all of the qus for
4,400 I believe and uh we're going to
sell it for
5026 so that 600k profit only took us
half an hour to combine the
items uh but you might already know this
if you actually watched my video okay so
distractions aside we are back to Telly
alen we're doing Rune Arrow right now
because we don't feel like waiting uh
for alal to buy right now or just want
to get this done so there is 73 magic
two more levels and we'll have 75 so
we're just going to grind that out right
now and uh just get it done okay so we
got another
1,600 alks in teleports uh we're losing
actually only
about 400k an hour to do this so it's
not not awful really uh for the magic
experience which we were still getting
about 120k an hour if I'm paying
attention um but yeah buy these fire
runes get back to it and yeah let's get
that 75 magic okay there we go there is
level 74 magic only one more level to go
we're in the zone we're getting this
done really quick and yeah one more
level okay so I'm pretty happy it looks
like we're going to have enough uh Al I
really just ballparked this um but yeah
we only have 23 cast left but I think
it's going to be enough to get 75 so
there is 75 magic we can now equip the
Trident of the Seas so I'm going to go
ahead and buy one of those charge it up
and see how good it is really all right
guys so we're at barrows this is what we
are wearing we have a Gothic smer AAS
accumulator combat bracelet am of Glory
we got the new tridon of the Seas we're
wearing we got Mystic robe top and
bottoms snakes skin boots Sears ring and
uh our Brun kite Shield um and we also
have a toxic blowpipe and some range
gear in our inventory got some prayer
potions some sharks and a dragon
Scimitar for when we're underground
trying to get the kill count so I've not
done this a whole lot we're going to see
how this goes and see what we get for my
first ever barrels
chest all right so we get to see how the
Trident Works uh it seems to have pretty
high consistent damage now I'm not sure
if this gear is very good at all because
apparently the brothers have zero magic
defense you can wear like plate armor if
you want um but I think for when you're
using the blowpipe on the rim you
definitely want some range bonus that's
my understanding of it so far but so far
this uh Trident is doing quite a bit of
damage and yeah he's pretty much dead
already well done okay so we're
underground and we're just fighting a
rim uh the toxic blowpipe is doing
pretty well too now we're using a lot of
prayer potions we definitely going to
have to change this up because using
even two prayer potions I mean that's
16k you're only getting like 30 40K in
profit per chest I mean without a piece
of course so yeah we're going to have to
see the best way to do this okay so for
my my first ever barrows chest let's see
what I end up getting we have gotten oh
my God there we go it is vero's plate
skirt first chest uh I didn't actually
think I'd be lucky but apparently I am
okay now for our second ever chest can
we get back to back
no uh kind of average got some runes got
some coins not too bad and our third
bearrows chest is pretty mediocre is as
well some runes some bolt racks uh but
yeah nothing special all right guys we
got another barrows chest coming in not
sure which one this is uh but pretty
shitty
runes but to be fair that's uh pretty
much what most of this
is okay I think this is chest number
seven or no chest number five sorry
again bolt racks blood runes I think
there's a 1 in 17 chance of getting the
barrows item so I mean I should have to
do another like 30 chests if I'm to
expect another Barrow item okay guys
here is our next chest not a whole lot
of loot that is chest number six uh but
yeah still can't complain okay in chest
number seven we get another Barack skirt
my guys are going to kill me wow that is
another 1.2 mil uh in seven barrows
chests that is 25 to 30 chest before on
average I should have gotten two items
in plus these are two pretty valuable
items there's a lot of items not worth a
whole lot yeah so so far I'm liking
barrows okay chest number eight is going
to
be uh some runes so and 1.6k chest
number nine bolt rcks and mind runes
okay and here is chest number 10 uh
decent amount of runes coins pretty
average here is chest number 11 and this
is the sketchiest one yet run six Health
with prayer let's get out here
um didn't get oh we got a decent amount
of runes but still Jesus we almost died
chest number 12 is going to be an elite
clue scroll oh my God what is the
chances of that I think we actually have
one of every clue scroll now interesting
well there we go another rare drop all
right guys that's about going to wrap it
up for today's episode uh we did about
12 barrels kills and we got two verac
skirts and an elite clue scroll it's
very lucky so I think we're going to
stop now and uh this was a bit of a
longer episode now do you guys want
longer episodes maybe 15 minutes to 20
minutes or is 10 to 12 minutes uh good
length for you guys uh if you wouldn't
mind leaving a comment down below I'd
love to hear you guys' opinions and on
that note as well um since these
episodes are taking a lot longer to make
and um I mean I I'm doing this because I
like doing it uh but I've uh heard that
YouTube has changed the way uh it
promotes your videos and a lot of that's
going to be based on interaction so I
don't want to be begging for likes
begging for comments if it's not going
to make a difference but that being said
I was hoping uh that you would all like
the video just to see for my from my own
perspective uh if it has an effect on
how much exposure the video gets uh so
if you wouldn't mind dropping a like I'm
not going to harass you every time about
this just kind of more of an experiment
experiment um to see if I end up if it
ends up doing better or not all right
guys hope you guys enjoyed the video
thanks a lot and I'll see you guys uh
next
[Music]
time